pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis houran en chine avec pissos scott
ressortissants camerounais
bonjour monsieur scott merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors vous vous
trouvez à wana l'épicentre de cette
épidémie due coronavirus car est la
situation actuellement sur place dont
jude est moins évident votre émission ou
l'instant la situation et c'est de se
stabiliser
nous voyons le gouvernement chinois qui
essaie d'endiguer cette situation la
plupart des populations sont encore
confiné à leurs chambres les
appartements il ya moins de circulation
quand les gens se déplacent ils doivent
le faire des masques les vivres des
carreaux nels en train de s'épuiser
progressivement mais là nous sommes en
contact avec notre ambassade et nous
essayons de voir comment aider la
communauté
alors on sait que
il y à un étudiant camerounais qui a été
infecté l'inquiétude d'ailleurs mon
temps chez les parents au cameroun
est-ce qu'ils ont raison de s'inquiéter
est ce que vous voulez ce autorités de
votre pays ont décidé d'un rapatriement
or pour l'instant je tiens d'abord à ti
cul nous avons confiance aux systèmes
sanitaires de la chine parce que nous
savons que nos pays ont peut-être des
difficultés en termes de logistique
ademe de détection parfois ou comment
traiter ce problème alors je dois vous
dire qu'ils se trouvent eux les solistes
pas beaucoup mieux
l'étudiant personnes nous ne sommes pas
encore au niveau de d'évacuation nous
sommes d'abord au niveau d'identifier
les besoins de la commune des voix
comment nous pouvons aider ces personnes
justement vous avez créé une application
mobile pour échanger entre étudiants
camourenais com comment ça se passe
concrètement qu'est ce que vous faites
pour vous aider les uns les autres
alors que vous devez justement suivre
certaines mesures imposées par les
autorités chinoises d'abord je tiens
d'abord à préciser que je ne parle pas
au nom des étudiants
en fait notre communauté constituée des
travailleurs et des étudiants
nous avons constitué une plateforme suis
l'application chinoise chat qui est là
pour rassembler tous les membres de
l'eca monnaie de la province du hubei
puisque ce n'est pas seulement la ville
de wuhan qui est concerné mais toute la
province et grâce à cette application
on essaie de l'identifier d'abord les
membres savoir ceux qui sont dans le
besoin
savoir quels sont les problèmes des
éléments on appris aujourd'hui
le décès d'une première victime non
chinoises à bourg ain justement un
américain âgé de 60 ans jusqu'à
maintenant ont parlé de victimes que
chinois finalement est-ce que
l'annoncent de ce décès a généré une
certaine psychose chez les étrangers qui
sont sur place comment est ce que vous
avez réagi
bon il est vrai que cette situation est
assez triste et ça nous inquiète mais
pour l'instant nous essayons de garder
le calme
nous essayons de nous encourager parce
que puis les chaussées décédé à la cicos
de ces de paniquer alors pour l'instant
nous essayons de nous encourager de voir
un peu comment s'entraider voir un peu
comment du pouvoir collaborer avec les
autorités pour sécourir vous veniez
année 2 au personnes de la communauté
très bien en tout cas merci beaucoup
monsieur pissos corte d'avoir répondu à
des questions je rappelle que vous êtes
entrepreneur camerounais a enchaîné